[Music]
podboy had pulled some exciting audio
that no longer has video form but um
this is older
but let's just this is from old episodes
of tiger belly when they were still when
um
uh brother [ __ ] and bobby were still
together
molested when i was eight years old i
felt sudden like
like an urge like a sexual urge to do
the same to either a pet
a doll or a real person
you know all right
she's just a walking red flag right in
every way
like
what is that
there are things that would be a deal
breaker for me
and there's certain times you'd have to
go look it's it's not even that i don't
like you or anything but
you're so [ __ ]
that i can't be around you know like
right you know i would almost feel bad
dumping for somebody that early but i
would have dumped her early unlike bobby
and i would have probably felt bad
you know i mean like man you know
sometimes you feel bad when you gotta
cut somebody loose but right right you
you are not gonna
improve you're just a [ __ ] borderline
serial killer pedophile a real child and
you know what i hate to say it now but
like my recollection of it stop i love
you stop
stop
i love you
stop
you want me to stop trying
to keep
no this is interesting go ahead was that
i took another cousin of mine i was
eight and she was six
and i you know what i mean that's like
there were things that i would probably
i don't i can't this is no no we're
listening to this we did that were
highly inappropriate for an
eight-year-old yeah because it was being
done to me yeah and i didn't i was so
confused i didn't feel the old lena
dunham excuse me like my family look i
don't even
blame
an eight-year-old for acting out they're
eight years old yeah if if something
happens to them i get all that
and i understand
going to a therapist
or a priest
or somebody
and talking about that and unburdening
yourself when you're older just
absolutely tell but like
this is a podcast this is supposed to be
like a funny fun podcast right like that
i don't know why you would
holy [ __ ] who the [ __ ] decides that
that's the [ __ ] format
or anyone that i felt protected well you
you know what i was molested myself too
and that's why you molested
you and your yeah
i won't say it then
whoa
[Music]
whoa
what
[Laughter]
hey dj run that back
yeah
family knew about it or anyone that i
felt protected well you know what i was
molested myself too
and that's why you molested
you and your what
i won't say it then
50th anniversary
wait what would you
what you were about to say that's why
you did some weird ass okay sexual [ __ ]
let me just say that
listen to me right now okay i don't know
what the [ __ ] she's talking about
all right
i never molested anybody
i was molested
and you stayed with her after this but
i'm just wondering what's going on here
done some things
that are suspect
but not to anyone outside of my nucleus
family sweetie uh there's absolutely
zero
molestation in a voluntary 69.
i want
i don't want to be around anymore
why did i take this [ __ ] job i
[ __ ] hate i [ __ ] hate you guys
that was a lot that was the last thing
frozen said too
if you if two people are
blowing each other that's not molesting
hey jj go to the bullpen start warming
up virginia might fry out
go get your thrown arm ready
nation that's like sheer sexual
bliss jason the bullpen with the [ __ ]
ricky vaughn glasses on with dip in his
mouth though i'm assuming jj has
different as well
all right jake's mint shoe jake sorry
murphy jake's mint chew well
i hate you good good synergy though i
don't know what you're talking about
yeah it's good to work well you don't
want to work in the jake's mint chew
live read in the middle of the kalila
bobby lee molestation clip i would argue
that they don't want us to do that
because you know jake's minchu has these
uh pouches they're
a wonderful mixture of mint i'm not
doing it again i already mentioned them
so i might as well get it done
uh
a combination of minted coffee pouches
that act just like they stimulate
dip
uh or chewing tobacco as a you know city
folk call it
and uh go to jake's minchi they also
have a variety of
handmade soaps cvd cbd gummies vapes and
all kinds of wonderful products promo
code rotc 10 off at jake's mint shoe
and uh yeah they got cbd pouches as well
so you can chill out while you also do
your fake dipping uh jake's minchu promo
code rotc
i can no longer talk about that
because if we keep talking about it that
one person
that 69 with is going to [ __ ] murder
me
and then i learned
because this is something that you
talked about in san diego
that's true and he said his name is
it's his brother isn't it is his brother
i thought it was i thought it was his
cousin if i remember correctly
i asked you was that the only
experience that you had and you were
like no there was this other time and i
was like okay well
okay because his excuses he was 11 years
old when this happened and that he was
on meth right and then he told me in the
different drinking really yeah if he was
11 years old he was probably molested
also meth
this show why is she keep talking
why is she ever talking different story
with somebody who with a real like guy
and i was like well how old are you i
was like he's like i don't know 16 17.
i was like bobby you're gay
she has tried to gaslight bobby until
he's a narcissist he's gay because he
was molested at 11 by the way he's gay
hold on what uh oh he shouldn't do asian
stereotypes you shouldn't do jamie foxx
movies
dude this man is so broke and this woman
broke her
i just need to defend myself
all right
this is that and i'm going to be
completely
transparent and honest
because i don't no longer want to talk
about it anymore okay
if you were to ask me have you had gay
experiences
the answer would be yes
have you had gay experiences more than
one time the answer would be yes
have you had gay experiences more than
30 times
the answer would be
no
oh it's a 20 yeah all right so 29 is the
limit that's that 28 and a half because
one of those one it was half and half we
jumped from two to thirty bobby
did you have 20 gay experiences because
i feel like can i say something and this
shows and their show gets to be mocking
their their show gets to be monetized
and r doesn't huh
yeah that's kind of
weird and what one more stop that orange
man a little 30 second tag on it to this
last one and i don't care what you guys
say about magnum pi i really enjoy it
who's saying anything i don't think that
i could ever do a show in hawaii i
thought you wanted to do a show in
hawaii but i can't do tiger belly then
yeah if he lives there for like three
quarters of a year he's not gonna be
able to do this she talked him out of
doing a show in hawaii by the way that's
what we're referring to here okay my
vote is no
my vote is no
you don't get a vote [ __ ] yeah so don't
even offer magnum
did people know that kalyan comes to
hawaii once a week
oh this is the
wait a second there's a guy that was
wait wait wait a second couldn't do the
guy i know couldn't do tiger belly
because he would be in hawaii too often
but now they're saying that kalila comes
to hawaii once a week so she talks about
that other guy
one time a week
in hawaii because then she would he'd be
[ __ ] up her side thing yeah now every
time every person looking at her saying
she's hot and she is hot
i just want to just just just throw some
reality in here so throw some cold water
on this if you would if you will
pretend the microphone she's holding is
an erect dog dick
still doing it for you
what if it's her brother
well some people probably i guess
[ __ ] she fought lou in the chat
earlier said yeah she [ __ ] her like
step brothers and dogs [ __ ] mo
replied but does she [ __ ] step dogs
bro you know what she looks like you
know this one looks what's that what's
this one's name again
annie letterman annie letterman she
looks like a woman that could roll a
blunt with the long fingernails at a car
going 150 miles per hour but doesn't
smoke
eyes back justin
that's just hey can you go back
yeah sure hold on sorry
it's like the thing is whenever she's on
only only collide that gets is allowed
to be on camera there you go she also
her camera sucks anyway go ahead she's
like she's like an aging
investigative reporter that used to be
hot who's like going undercover at a
rave
exactly yes like it's like a 50 year old
jewish woman dressed up like a 13 year
old like
it's like it's like if you had an adult
like decoy trying to catch pedophiles
yes
yeah and they were like i don't know man
i mean i don't have anybody's that
convincing but i mean
we just dress annie up like she's
[ __ ] 12.
[Laughter]
honestly that's what she is she's a
wiggler the pedophile shows up to the
sting and he sees her and he's like no
thanks
she said
i feel like i kind of got tricked here
she's she's she's a wigger taylor lorenz
[Laughter]
she looks like she cleans up [ __ ]
insulin needles out of a back alley with
a suboxone strip in her mouth
[Laughter]
she looks like she would spit out your
comment into her hand and shove it up
her [ __ ] to get child support
or something like that
yeah pregnant job hit on her because she
definitely looks like somebody who's
blown people in trucks before
no she's blown
up she spun people in her own truck
before
that's right
adjusted to the podcast i think that's
just about right
oh that's it hey thank you pod pod boy
puts these up by the way pod boy he's
like a thousand subs but he finds a lot
of good stuff so subscribe to pod boy if
you haven't already